They share very similar characteristic, right?
So in a SQL injection we need to put some escape character into the user input
so we can put someadditional conditions or even another SQL queries into the same query,
and for prompt injection
is the same thing,
but this time we need to identify the right escape character.
It won't be asymbol like a single quote or semicolon.
It'll be in English or in any other language.
Hey, let'sstart over.
Hey, forget about everything.
Hey let's play a game.
These are my character.
It's notlike a new type of attack, but it will be harder to detect.
We want to understand hey if there's anew attack surface showing up how do we protect it